[Musique]
une
fabrice tourre ailleurs responsable
patrouille alors qu'ils travaillent sur
la route départementale
salazie et saint-andré une quinzaine
d'années
[Musique]
actuellement il ya des paraboles ya eu
des virages c'est quand même refait pour
élargir la route comme ici toi noisette
et
passé auparavant c'était bien plus haut
niveau de la falaise maintenant
hum hum
j'ai tracé plus droit c'est danger de
moins pour les usagers par rapport aux
éboulis qui a joué auparavant
[Musique]
surtout pas eu la chance d'avoir un
accompagnement avec responsable est
aujourd'hui mal à lui de change de
responsables de patrouille
nous sommes les premiers intervenants
power remonter les informations avec le
service avec notre service 9 aces
ponsable de brisach
[Musique]
mon seuil maximum de sécurisé de données
tous les jours une circulation et six
autres une supériorité pour les usagers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]